welcome back everybody to the h3 podcast
live this episode is sponsored by
movement quit wink and elder scrolls
legends a little bit about some nice
sponsor just a reminder we are crushing
it on Spotify which the podcast is now
up on we're number one there so keeps
going there we are also up on soundcloud
now we had a lot of requests to get the
podcast up there so we are on spotify
we're on soundcloud keep that [ __ ] wait
introducing our guest listen he's my
he's frankly my favorite guest on this
podcast I think it's your third time on
she joy to privilege post Malone hello
thanks for coming thanks for coatsy
thanks for having me on again oh yeah
pleasure to have you here so how you I
mean I haven't seen you a little bit
you've been on tour right your fault or
let me get that lighter oh yeah
let's go I haven't been on tour I've
just been traveling the world and it's
drinking slam and cheers by the way
it's all the shows are just shows are
just statues part two mmm I like to
consider it a journey nice so the travel
is free the shows are incidental yeah
this shows the shows just happen you
happen to be in Italy and you're like
huh I'm just there I like that I like
that thought no but I've been yeah I've
been traveling a lot and getting [ __ ]
done and it's tiring but I always think
that touring looks so exhausting it is I
look like [ __ ] now you look at me you're
killing it bro I love that you just the
great thing is that you just embrace
your authentic dude you're who you are
like you just [ __ ] you're killing
just a guy exactly just a guy was
beautiful blue eyes right well then I
guess that means you are more just
I'm really just the guy your eyes look
like hamburgers thank you so much you're
more than just a guy with a couple
hamburgers in his eyes better since then
you've been just a little recap here but
Rockstar number one on Billboard's is
it's still number one right [ __ ] me like
two months now not for long my mom has
been texting me every time it's playing
with my mom to my mom
I could tell your mom's lovely I was
super cool every time I go to a friend's
house they'd always say like your mom
did what a guy no that's not where's
your mom I don't care about you yeah
nice to see you man your mom here uh mom
by the way I'm gonna cigarette since the
last time we hung out but I love our
traditional just why are you trying to
stop no I'm I'm just not a smoker but I
like to get weird and wild you know When
in Rome you don't have like a douche
flute or a mouth for Dora you got a big
one a douche flute it's first of all
okay what would you call the giant babe
I don't know it's got it the Canon has
to be the what's the first trade it's
kind of have more of an alliteration or
rhyming not really cuz mouth fedoras
kind of just I'm have to think on that
yeah it's like a [ __ ] douche pack had
it like a camel back and have it that
thing I don't know if I talked about it
yet was so [ __ ] heavy do we talk
about when we first got out on the
street we had this prop company built it
and then we
out to Hollywood to film and the moment
I put it on I swear to god it's like 80
pounds and the moment I put on I was
like oh my [ __ ] god how am I gonna
make it through this day I saw Dan
coming up the escalator to meet us and
he was like holding it and I was like
what is this guy [ __ ] exaggerating
how heavy this thing is
I put it on I was like I don't know how
I get through this day after five
minutes the strap broke it's just
completely buckled under its weight it
was pretty dramatic day we had to go to
like it was the hottest day yeah you
look great
I feel yeah that's nice that's right I
kept that by the way you should treat
yourself yeah I kept that Queen I'm
waiting I'm hoping honestly I can't wait
for us to go to Vegas I want a gun I'm
gonna wear that now that I have good
shoes yes you always show me up so yeah
I think I think Vegas is like my escape
from the norm because I get to wear fun
stuff I'm gonna buy a matching suit you
guys should if we ever have low be cute
a red-carpet event won't go wearing
matching Gucci track suits is he super
cute you guys are killing it I'm so
happy you're killing it did I tell you
speaking of Vegas did I tell you that
story about when I won like 95 grand
this is a new story I think no okay so I
was in Vegas this isn't like a nice
anecdote I love that no yeah this is a
great nice anecdote from Vegas those are
rare yeah yeah no it's not nice
I beat but it's a great story that's a
nice story but it's not nice because it
just shows the ignorance of me okay so
here's the deal so I go it's like you
know I usually go like 15 grand ready to
go cash ready to play and so I I we were
playing blackjack my mom was there and I
think she was there I don't know if she
was there maybe not
okay so sat down at this blackjack table
right at 14,000
I played it all up and down whatever but
along the way I gave some money to Jason
you know Jason my friend he lives with
me
he's the ER yeah yeah and I gave him a
hundred bucks he lost that hand and then
I gave him another hundred and he
started winning and at that time I was
still playing my like 14 grand right and
so up and down I lost it all I say Jason
give me 100 bucks and then I lose that
exactly I got it I gotta get a return on
my investment and then I lose that I
tell him give me another hundred bucks
and I've that hundred dollar i sat at
the table for 14 hours play had like 50
screwdrivers worked my way up from $100
to 95 thousand dollars so and I said
okay as soon as I get two hundred
thousand I'm walking away gamblers
fallacy I'm walking away at a hundred
thousand ninety-five I was like it was
crazy they had like five thousand dollar
chips I just had a shitload of them
interestingly the more money you have on
the table the less chips it looks like
you yeah yeah yeah yeah there were like
British colors that I started saying at
the British national anthem like LED
lights and yeah so I 95 thousand okay
I'm gonna play til a hundred thousand
went down to five thousand dollars and
then I went all the way back up to
ninety five thousand dollars not how
long did that take 14 hours I didn't get
up I did not move I was just drinking
and every time I would win cuz I was
playing like $10,000 hands and then
doubling the crowd yeah I was big it was
a big time for section oh okay so you
were at High Roller is a scam yeah I
don't like it there act normal I don't
like it there the max bet was like was
10,000 yeah you know what the high
rollers places it's just sad who's like
the press oh it is the person there's
nobody's there there's all these
gambling addicts who come and like lose
their [ __ ] yeah it's crazy it's crazy
but yeah I mean I won that lost the 95
again playing vague and
that's my story but it was it was really
a rush every time I would win like a
hand I would literally take run up and
take a lap around it was the most
intense thing of my life and it was a
lot of sounds like no regrets there yeah
I mean yeah twice
two times two times and I didn't get
that extra five just to get a hundred
and walk away so how did you imagine
walking away with a hundred grand cash
you would have been up on that kiss you
know yeah a lifetime yeah
they would be following you back yeah
they were they they yeah it was they had
like there were security gate like four
security guards they been like knocking
at your door like hello you know we're
so open yeah we gotta come back come on
I do feel walking away were you like oh
I'm sad or were you like that was a fact
it was very but now I look back and I
said hey that's pretty cool anyways it's
a great story a great anecdote great
anecdote thanks for sure that hey you're
welcome
appreciate that dude I'm so sore I feel
like I we started we got a personal
trainers I can't do it looks great
oh thanks Doug he's only done one okay
when is it every day I do it twice a
week I've done it twice I I do it twice
a week it's the thing I've done in one
week but anyway I'm so sore I cannot
even stand up I like this thing of like
where we're gonna get you more muscular
I mean what you're like I can't [ __ ] it
I feel like I'm 19
oh yeah yeah I'm getting serious yeah
yeah after show I need to do like the
like stretches because it might like
these things these groin things right
like the little like tendons right
that's my worst spot because you do a
lot of like kneeling and [ __ ] yeah it's
good exercise it is yeah I mean I'm
surprised I mean I'm so a thick boy yeah
yeah what I mean think what for I never
like I feel old yeah well you're busy
you work a lot I have a living
playing call of duty god mm-hmm you need
to get on it yeah I was talking to you
about that I've never I've never played
caught I never played battlefield or Cod
or any of those console Cod is fun this
one is fun I've been seeing I was
thinking about buying and I saw mixed
reviews almost farmer review [ __ ] well
see the reviews you probably were
reading was like very glitchy right
right a lot of what we're like it's not
worth it by yet oh it is now really yeah
we should play together
yeah geometry wars oh [ __ ] I played like
the first one you have yeah so there's
involved involved
well like okay and the first one it's
just a flat plane and all these crazy
waves right I remember that anyway so
now that it's been evolved and it has a
thing so it's to the three why there's
like freaking trapezoids and pills
you're all and globes is a skewed yes
good yes there's skews there's planes
damn dimension sounds very it's right
really in Ted we had a friend over I
think we must have played it for like 10
hours really yeah really
like Max 20 minute game it's like peggle
so we should play cod or I don't know I
want to play pub G with you but I want
it up so over that game I want it's the
thing that really pisses me off is I
always get killed by some [ __ ] hacker
really every time how do you know
they're hacking because they should be
through three wall I always landed
George Paul and I'll be inside of the
inside of the crate and they'll shoot me
through the crate that's a [ __ ] it's
[ __ ] well there's no Pettit one time
I was playing yeah there's no
penetration know what time I was playing
and I dropped from the sky
and none of the buildings rendered and I
could see through all the walls and I
could walk through walls that's really
good so I so I did you were so let's so
I was it I should have right like I'm
walking through walls I can see everyone
I'm picking everything I'm about the
best gear I'm capping people through
walls and [ __ ] this is just no walls in
the game so there's a dude in the
[ __ ] tree and I'm capping him through
like a ten you know walls and you see
through trees everything nothing existed
I know I couldn't see through trees but
I see him like Oh building you know like
this [ __ ] loser
I lost like two walls and I'm trying to
shoot him and it's a frustrating game I
love the game my frustration comes from
legitimate kills cuz yeah I never know
where I'm being shot from yeah I guess
the answer was hackers the whole time
any time I lose yeah I mean like reasons
why you actually lose is like 1% and
[ __ ] [ __ ] is 99% hackers it's
like a pie chart have you seen that pie
chart
yes it's I live that pie chart right we
should play some though you think you
fun I think God okay I'm Arnie like
third prestige that sounds very
prestigious prestige over look where you
can hang out with all your rich friends
let's do that um I'd love to do that
yeah it's nice it's good even I wouldn't
lead you wrong I want to play I want to
play play let's wrap it up I saw you the
other day you on martha's snoop yeah why
should that I have so many questions
about it because I we mean ela or well I
don't we're thinking a lot about how
shows are made right I'm not gonna say
why
and I'm wondering how people make it
right first my first question is how
long ago was that shot I want to say it
was a long time ago okay
months okay Oh - maybe half a year maybe
mmm Wow maybe five months yeah and so my
next question is when you're there it's
when they like do the audience reaction
it sounds like there's like a whole
stadium of people there there is a lot
of people there is hilarious yeah um
there was a lot of people there would
you say whole stadium yeah but it was
nice because everybody you know did you
get to see the audience yeah yeah yeah
it's nice okay yeah did they cook did
they actually cook their own food and
wait mmm so soup made that fish and it
cooked for you cuz they cut out because
they were like alright snoops gonna make
this fish and put it in the oven and
then oh my god it's done immediately so
you were hanging out that whole time
right well it was more like a uh I'd say
more like a cooking show you know how
like they show you how to make it
already right and then so then they cook
the one that they already made that's
exactly the same as got it yeah so that
was pre pour like pre-prepped I would
say so I don't know yeah okay but it was
they was delightful it was a treat it
was a real treat being on the show yeah
Matt Wendy oh we had that Wendy was
super cool super super sweet
Martha was super sweet she liked my car
though I'm talking about that you give
her a spin make a pass did you stop you
take a pic from psycho you stop short
with my wife oh is that like whenever
that's the mom arm yeah it's a wall in
Seinfeld it's a dad it's like a boom no
no I mean in my life
it's Seinfeld it's like you have a hot
date and then you see a red light and
then you act like you don't see it and
then you slam on the brake to stop short
and you put your hand out okay yeah it's
the same it's the same concept except
without the nod eNOS in short you could
have just stopped short with Martha oh
she was driving oh maybe she could stop
everyone wants a couple e's next I mean
I've got stuff I saw you were in ghost
hunters yeah Ghost Adventures yeah it's
awesome how would that go was it really
spooky it was crazy it was crazy they're
gonna be here we should do like a online
special yeah I love because we went to
that place and it was pretty spooky we
heard that voice
but this that like the things that they
get into is really crazy and they have
all the equipment and stuff like yes
well that guy's the real deal yeah I was
surprised but how's it house a show
called Ghost Adventures Ghost Adventures
it's on History Channel right travel
travel it's the number one show on
droughts on travel and it's on like the
30th the season or some [ __ ] like what
17 now okay I mean how many is there
that many goes well I've been watching
the show since I was 12
Wow
[Music]
is that one of the most surreal yeah
getting to meet Zach and he's such a
good guy and you know he lives in Vegas
so he always gambling have fun and
that's cool and it was super cool used
to ask my mom to stay up late watch
that's the doorman I get to go on it the
most surreal like the celebrity cuz now
you've met so many cool people
what are were the some of the most
surreal like celebrity encounters you've
had where you're like I cannot believe
I'm hanging out with this guy
just a lot of stuff from my childhood
you know what I mean like I got to hang
out with the guys from a band called
Escape the Fate I used to listen to all
the time and high school and stuff and
meeting them was super sick I'm like
Chris drew from nevershoutnever I don't
know if y'all know them but I used to
listen to him all the time and I just
like started talking to him like hitting
him up and you know he said hi and also
one time i DM the guy from Fleet Foxes
Robin Peck mode and that's my favorite
band of all time and he responded back
so just virtual winter dance I think the
most real experience you know getting a
little DM back is meaningful yes it is
the most surreal one I've had probably
is with Steve oh yeah like having
steve-o because before we shot that
video with him he came over to our house
and we were in our living room like
shooting the [ __ ] about YouTube
pranksters and stuff right and I was it
was just so [ __ ] sir cuz I grew up
watching Jack like we all did right
mm-hmm Steve owes a legend one he's
sitting in my living room when we're
talking [ __ ] about like Fatali making
fun of this guy and I was just like so
outside myself being like this is so
weird
hanging out with Steve right yeah it's
like you don't even know yet to stop and
say [ __ ] yeah I don't want to be weird
but it's just like what even is my life
right now man
alright so it keeps hitting me up - oh
so we need to do this video quick our
fans are always asking about it the rock
star has been number one for a minute
some apple meat yeah yeah if not on
Apple in my heart alright so I got so
much stuff that I want to get to today
we have so many videos and stories and
scoops to watch we're gonna have so much
fun here today
let's go and do that ad break and then
get into well let me let's start with
this first story cuz I start with this
first one
you remember Patrice Wilson yeah okay
then where this one the weirdest one
this [ __ ] creeped me out it's gotta be
[ __ ] pretty weird I think you and
everyone watching is gonna be shot okay
yeah don't stand I need a cigarette
I'm not overselling this you guys I
swear to God okay yeah let's go I needed
[ __ ] need to settle my nerves so
Patrice Wilson for those of you who
don't know he makes like he made Friday
he made Friday he made all these videos
with this little blonde girl Allison
gold very pet Oh weird creepy vibes and
all them we made a lot of videos making
fun of him a long time ago so recently
just a couple of days ago he erased all
the videos on his channel and he all he
has now is a live stream a live one live
stream with a countdown I'm gonna I'm
gonna pull it up right now hang out one
sex but hold on it gets weird or not
it's kind of dad that's the question
here Patrice Willis I don't know why I
don't have this link you don't have the
link this is so inappropriate with me oh
yeah here it is
oh he changed the [ __ ] yeah here it is
okay alright so here is he erased all of
his videos he changed the logo of his
channel to the shadowy creepy icon okay
it's him in a hood and look at the title
it's counting down until December 1st
that's turned in 19 hours and look at
this cryptic [ __ ] it just says it's like
a bunch of gibberish and then at the end
it says
h3h3 what do you think the weirdest part
is like this shadowy icon he looks like
player unknown like how do I get a
better look at that yeah he's a ring
Wraith and I don't know what this is he
like blocked out the eyes that's a video
we've made oh yeah right okay yeah
videos that's from the LCC that's a
great song
that's number one of my Chinese stuff
like a pan that was cuddling her so like
what oh there's a hundred people
watching this right now it's very
entertaining stream by the way a shout
out to our new video which is currently
in the sidebar educational videos hey
got him got him oh wow okay I need to
login to ie to catch up is from
yesterday I'm will hold it against you
well it should I be concerned about this
what it is changed he's watching you eat
it and just change what if it says
something what if it says something just
wait until something else comes up it
was like I'm freaked out
somebody says maybe it was hacked but I
don't know he seems like a pretty tech
savvy guy okay and so somebody manually
just changed them huh
well it's bad how could he react that
fast huh wait it's just cycling between
them is it though yeah oh my god you
here what is that creepy [ __ ] screen
dude I have chosen that screen is so
creepy it's like a CD screen like a
screen with like guck and he was just
moving behind it no it's not a screen
[Laughter]
should I remove this that's a real
screen that's actually a live screen are
you sure yes what I'm freaked out I'm
legitimately scared should I close this
probably I don't know what if he comes
out with like a kid's head and then what
yeah I'll find out later I'll find out
later we were looking at it yesterday
and it was just black with the contact
he's watching
did he bait me what because he put a ch3
in the title did he bait me into putting
that like he expected my reaction to to
show this on the podcast like well if he
was doing that why would he just move
behind the screen weird why wouldn't he
come out and say 'i hate you he's gonna
kill us both on December 1st Oh me not
you me and you I I am legitimately
thought about my what security you sure
yes okay yeah what's the best card for
home security shotgun that's what I've
heard
oh my get a shot he put it under my bed
yeah that's what my uncle says he it's
Friday Friday little less than a week or
two weeks before December first takes 10
days to get one in California I do I
have a felony in my past is that a
problem I don't think so these days what
does it mean no which is a stupid rule
anyways wait you can't buy if you have
no in California that's weird they're
like California has the worst laws
that's so strange you're like if you've
been to sitting like this guy that
happen recently
I don't wasn't in California the guy who
was dishonorably discharged for like
yeah he was in California yeah so he I
don't know it was in California but I
heard about this guy he's like yeah you
can buy a gun but if you ever smoked
weed in your life we don't trust you
crazy all right let's take a break I
need to get some fresh air after I'm
we were just he's watching more creepy
Patrice I'm sorry dude I was all in good
fun I wish you the best I think you're
talented guy
I although I've made fun of you in the
past you know I think you're really
talented filmmaker and please don't
murder me and whatever you have on that
curtain maybe it's better that you just
keep that to yourself
you're dead he's coming after all of us
he's but a challenge if you're watching
confirm change the title to h3 h3 - post
Malone also we're gonna check back after
the break and see if he updated that
until then guys a quick word from our
sponsors and and we will be right back
thank you thank you - and VMT oh my god
oh look at this beautiful watch that
actually looks so good on you thank you
pulling it off and VMT watches
pronounced movement was founded on the
belief that style shouldn't break the
bank the watchmakers goal is to change
the way consumers think about fashion by
offering a high-quality minimalist
product at a revolutionary price
changing the world without chopping off
heads nice or maybe a couple heads can
roll but with the quality and price at
this mhm you know it's it's worth the
cost you gotta crack a couple eggs with
over a million watches sold to customers
in 160 plus countries around the world I
wonder why they do the plus and not just
say specific it's probably 161 what with
161 countries around the world movement
watches has solidified itself as the
world's fastest growing watch company
guys listen up we get the holiday
shopping can be tough but thanks to
movement all the gift-giving anxiety can
disappear with the press of a button
these watches make the perfect purchase
for just about anyone in your life guy
or girl and remember they only start at
$95 which afford this quality of a watch
get real these usually cost 500 plus
dollars where you're usually shopping
these guys they have the hook-up because
they cut out the middleman let me tell
you get 15% off to day with free
shipping and free returns by going to
envy empty and the and t.com slash h3
now is the time to step up your watch
game guys go to nvm t.com slash h3 this
watch has a really clean design that
makes a great fashion statement my
friends joined the movement I love my MV
MT watch
that's a movement thank you so much to
them for sponsoring us a great gift for
any guy or girl
and next up we have clip the vibrating
tube with bristles attached that we all
know and love okay listen I'm obsessed
with oral hygiene quip makes the best
best toothbrush can I lay it out any
easier for you guys it's a vibrating
toothbrush at times how long you need to
brush your teeth it's incredibly
affordable and it's incredibly good I'm
obsessed with bristle softness and and
and it's either it's too soft or it's
too hard they managed to find that
perfect medium and I'll tell you what
they don't even use like traditional
bristles it's like soft rubbery it's
it's interesting and it works better
than anything I've used I'm a quip guy
all right I'm pissed off dude equips
incredible product now listen I
challenge you to give me a gift that's
affordable practical and
instagram-worthy
tone it down you guys I love it but I
don't know if it's instagram-worthy on
top of that list is quit the electric
toothbrush what looks like was designed
by Apple without the high price let me
show you I'm telling you dude this thing
is it's do you hear that it's the
pleasure and joy that comes out of this
tube
you put in your mouth you just let it
take you away and then all the sudden
you come away you're clean you're happy
you're like oh my god you ever you ever
rub your teeth like that and it squeaks
squeaky clean
that's what quip stands for now listen
up it's just in time for the holidays
quip is the ideal size and price to gift
anyone on your list you can even include
an automatic brush head delivered for a
year to ensure your gift keeps giving
until the next holiday I would be
thoughtful of you wouldn't it the quip
electric toothbrush is featured in just
about every Gift Guide this year
including Oprah's o
List men's health which I was recently
featured on the cover of any other tool
and GQ that stands for gentlemen quality
I got nothing but they did gentleman use
this toothbrush so you know quip is
backed by a network of over 10,000
dental professionals including dentists
hygienists and dental students well you
know you've already got the endorsement
of the dentist you don't need dental
students like you got my endorsement
forget the students I take care of my
teeth and that's why I use quip so
listen up quip starts at just 25 bucks
that is a great price for a toothbrush
this good okay right now when you go to
get quipped calm slash h3 get your first
refill pack free with a quip electric
toothbrush that's your first refill pack
free at grab get quick calm / h3 that's
GE t qu IP dot-com / h3 thank you to get
equip for making an incredible product
that makes my mouth squeak and vibrate
welcome back everybody still here with
post Malone and still creeped the FL
yeah still alive so I'm still like yeah
for like 12 more days yeah yeah we the
timer runs out at 12 o'clock a.m. on
December 1st so I'm not gonna put that
back on the screen because I'm frankly
I'm terrified of what may actually pop
up but Dan and backstage has it open so
if anything weird happens we will update
you guys I just hope it's a dis track we
were saying before it might be I love
that I'd actually don't have a lot of
fun with that but the fact that he
checked out all those videos that's
pretty extreme pretty dramatic but it's
been so long it's like dude the window
is gone kind of right so maybe not maybe
that's just how long it takes to build
like a nail bomb he's been working on oh
he's got like he's got this crazy disc
track and then the footage is all like
hidden camera footage peeking in our
window at our house what was that
I guess 50 cent went and checked up on
someone I don't remember who it was but
their mom at work she was like napping
and he was in there I don't want to
freaked out I don't know so every time
you've heard a little weird noise at
night in our house no no you know
nothing like what not we all like do not
get my head I'm not talking about
Patrice I'm talking about maybe it's
just like a little crack yeah when the
temperature goes down or Rises yeah
nature but we have another mystery to
work through explain that one okay so
today we came here to the office uh-huh
and then the table over there it was
empty except for this paper and no one
knows no one knows where I came from
fold it up brand-new a memo from 2012
about Mathnasium yeah nothing easier
isn't Mathnasium like a math website
it's a yeah that's a chain they have
brick-and-mortar stores folded up neatly
on our table the only person here was
Dan and he you know he says it wasn't
him
well that's a weird thing to have 2012
all employees bereavement pay is
calculated based on the bit they're
talking about bereavement pay and then
they're talking about jury doo doo doo
dee doo doo doo so what is it letter
about it's a memo all employees who wish
to take off due to the death of
immediate family members should notify
their superiors immediately how many how
many people are dropping dead in the
family here mo is this related why is it
there I don't know and I have no idea
why it was like brand-new like just like
you know one fold like that what's on
our desk wasn't a wrinkled what desk
right outside that day at that coffee
table so who is it related to this dream
well no jokes aside like I'm really
genuinely don't understand how this got
there and he doesn't no no no I did tell
him if there was an investigation that
would be the first guy yeah he would be
the suspect for sure who Dan she comes
here I don't know that he then is it you
and then he took dance kind of taking a
long time to respond yeah yeah why did
it take so long any updates on the
Wilson aider weird yeah so in the in the
description of that video there's a
bunch of links and I clicked on one of
them in a post video came up no no
you're kidding no not what it's not the
top result but like you click on this
link
dude you're [ __ ] you're a nice with us
and that should spin they're down I
don't think he changed okay I'm gonna
come out and look at it real quick I'll
put it up hold up
I don't want I want to look at it I
don't want it to be stuck there okay so
Austin's gonna come check that out we'll
report tot yeah when you're out there
Austin talking to the mics ex describe
your situation damp give him the mic so
everyone can follow along with his
amazement so describe what you're seeing
out there Austin give him the mic did
you find the chat or at least one person
is saying it's not a loop okay we're
pretty far down oh yeah how about that
but it also comes up with minecraft
adventure time but that's weird
yeah people in the chat are saying it's
not a loop by the way no you're on his
[ __ ] hit list you're an associate
you're an accomplice get some shotguns
on the door I told I told you I'm like
let's be gone on December 1st let's be
out of town on December 1st yeah I don't
want to be in any location that I rigged
it's like that scene from Lord of the
Rings are you scared not nearly enough
three first one yeah start Lord of the
Rings yeah Fellowship of the Ring yeah
Fellowship all right let's move on so
here have you heard of Boston Dynamics
no so these guys make AI robot well not
AI but they make these incredible robots
okay
they were bought recently by Google okay
watch this this is a new video of theirs
look at this thing
these are gonna kill us all someday and
if it near future
I mean I could do that watch this hold
on did you do
hey God oh dude he's got so much spring
here stuck the way what do you think
about that why does he need to do back
foot why does he need to be able to do
it back for some day these these like
Jackie Chan ass robots are gonna be
dodging bullets why does he need that's
the whole thing though why does he need
to be able to do a back foot so actually
what they're doing is they're building
the super yes yes for military use
powerful or for like transporting goods
their physical gymnastic robots they're
gonna they're gonna compete in the
Olympics next year really yeah they're
gonna be the American team they just
dress it say I'm a human but they're
gonna weaponize the [ __ ] of it
that's yeah essentially and like here
watch this one this is you and you want
to know why you want to know why these
robots are gonna kill us Sunday let me
show you what the [ __ ] they're doing to
these poor robot
look at this [ __ ] you think this robots
not gonna remember this you think he's
not gonna remember this we're all gonna
die because of this [ __ ] with the
hockey stick why can you only walk that
fast see he can do the lips and [ __ ] no
I mean even though the other guy was a
lack of that fast
he's not the bakflip robot it's a
different that that's the team 3000 this
is the t10 do you seriously think that
this robot is not gonna remember the
ship leave him alone man is he gonna get
up probably they always get up and they
never forget this is being controlled or
no this is all self oh my god
do not bully this robot because he does
not forget he's pleased over it he's
sick of his [ __ ] strip club he's sick of
this [ __ ] dude to the Robo bar and that
he's free he's free at last there's so
many uh-oh the way he got up was crazy
one like watch this [ __ ] if you want to
be creeped out
well it was like a thousand videos
playing now they taking over yeah how's
this make you feel that's a robot mm-hmm
he's terrifying
okay they got him right in the middle of
the uncanny valley like right just think
the way that he moves how do you feel
about this this guy he opens your door
he's in your hallway doing exactly this
motion he takes off the mask
you expect it to be a robot it's Patrice
Wilson
jumping jacks what are you doing oh oh
we've got we got a development on oh no
no no no my stomach just Chuck what
happened I didn't want that what
happened tell me it's like a live stream
now of looks like a cell phone feed in a
forest what yeah you got to see this I
don't know should I put in I guess I
have to yeah if it's like a kid's head
we'll just edit it out and post I'm like
anxious alright okay I'm pulling I'm
pulling it up this shit's creepy man
Patrice what are you doing why are you
doing this
he's got a audience now oh no it is
these are cell phones feed what are you
doing that trees why is it sideways so
you know he's a phone you idiot this is
like from a horror movie
is this why is he going to church is
that a church who's buried in that house
dude what are you doing that's a church
oh my god it's a [ __ ] Church is it no
maybe it looks like Scott is like
steeple yeah but it looks very
residential at the same time there's a
ladder in the back
it's very chairs you were scared what
it's Patrice if you're listening can you
just can you correct that what's gonna
be in the house dude should we watch
this there we go
where does he live I have no [ __ ] I
mean last I I knew he was in LA but this
does not look like LA oh this is a house
oh no I'm so terrified dude he's just
gonna cut it off so there's a ladder
he's walking up behind a house it's it
looks very rural looks very country it's
very very stuttering there's a lot of
lag
I guess here's a pork there's another
house right next to it
let's but it's kind of I mean it doesn't
look like la it's a nice house for sure
very wooded are we just gonna see it
dick all this and he's gonna like put in
his pants or something if he's he gonna
go in this house to murder someone oh
man
at what point do we close this I mean
it's not what he's going in what do you
think I don't know you're goes I'm alone
how much can you tolerate I don't know
this is gone this is real though yeah
yeah I mean ghosts are like one thing
but this is what is this blue [ __ ]
there's a tarp he walked around the back
he's in the backyard there's a zoomed he
zoomed in on the garage it's not your
house that's not my own Oh trust me I
would be fired beyond
he's zooming in slowly on some red
object in the garage white you'll are
you afraid of actually seeing something
or you just think this is a waste that's
creepy why is there ladders everywhere
on the house there's literally ladders
everywhere he's climbing up one of the
ladders but it looks like wait he looks
like a home-invasion thing cuz he has a
ladder going up to the balcony no but
you could just walked up the stairs
right but yeah I guess you're right
why what the [ __ ] dude do I close this
semester's oh I saw Han I saw a hand I
saw Patricia's hand it was a black told
you he was gonna cut it off didn't I
it'll be back he tried he changed the
font okay I'm not I can't watch I saw
his hand it's definitely him cuz we were
saying maybe it's a hacker but I saw you
guys it was his hand was a black man's
hand what there's only one black man
it's Patrice I mean it looked like oh my
god alright alright I'm gonna close this
Dan Kim let us know if there's any
updates oh my god
it's got a audience so if you're gonna
do some weird [ __ ] Patrice we don't wait
for that count then all right I'm
closing it you lost your chance
have you ever seen that how do we move
on past this I think we just do Patrice
watch let's do it but tonight let's
let's make him angry let's not let's
let's provoke him these statements are
endorsed by Austin wrote the script for
the show this is all endorsed by him all
right
so did you hear about a hard hard shift
here 180 have you heard about the new
Star Wars game for iea yeah battle was
it called - how it's like apparently
they're just [ __ ] everybody over with
DLCs what do you mean the game costs 80
bucks first of all the whole day it's
just to buy the retail copy the normal
game yeah 80 bucks
really and so the normal is 60 when I
actually am interested in playing this
game by 80 bucks it's like get real okay
no problem so basically there's so much
DLC in this eighty dollar game it
doesn't even include Darth Vader as a
playable character you have to either
play for like a thousand plus hours to
earn the credits to unlock him or pay
like an additional 50 bucks to unlock
him okay there's 4000 plus dollars of
DLC content to fully unlock this $80
game really 1600 maybe I saw the
collector's edition but anyway so
everyone was complaining like services
posted on reddit so seriously
he only pulled up I paid seriously I
paid $80 selves a door locked and so the
developers responded and this response
has entered the internet Hall of Fame
it's the most disliked comped comment of
all time
- 676 thousand good they go the intent
is to provide players with a sense of
pride and an accomplishment for
unlocking different heroes sips beer as
for cost we selected initial values
based upon the data from the open beta
someone said I wonder if I worked at
Burger if Burger King wants to sell me a
sense of pride and accomplishment by
making me work ten hours for my [ __ ]
fries so these and then if that's not
bad enough you know boogie right yeah so
he was streaming playing him to the game
enjoying it like a good boy trying to
earn credits to unlock Vader or whoever
else watch this clip having a lot of fun
more credits available in three hours
Wow it's like an app it's a proof
freemium we're sorry you were enjoying
our Kaede mode too much so we have to
stop giving you prizes I'm sorry I'm
sorry
were you enjoying arcade mode because
you have to wait three hours now to get
more credits out of arcade mode what the
[ __ ]
so he's [ __ ] [ __ ] me what's that
well this $60 game is now being treated
like a freemium mobile game yeah can you
believe these four these [ __ ] guys at
EA so this is it I'm boycott I actually
really want to play this game it looks
really fun but I don't know I mean this
said like I don't like it then they're
at love Star Wars but the thing that I
don't like about it is you don't reload
and that's what really pisses me off
you got it adds a new element of
strategy well no yeah reloading is just
satisfying and also its lasers like I
want I want like ballistic all right you
know you know into the future you want
you want gunpowder it's the ground yeah
boots on the ground kind of guy yeah but
in the future certainly they'll have to
reload I mean lasers what you got a
energy yeah exactly reload your energy
cells come on energy cell get with it
idiots that's so anyway I thought that
was interesting yeah that's crazy it is
a [ __ ] it's like [ __ ] clash of
clans or whatever
yeah it's clashing $60 clash of clans do
we have any calls I guess not
where I'm having a problem with discord
eh is that what's going on out there oh
yeah how was a I thought you were in
idubbbz contact Cobb obviously how was
that he's awesome yeah that was it was
after that night I think oh so the real
that was fueled by real emotions and
because he came he drove from here to LA
to here or not LA where he lives hmm to
her to Vegas yeah and I had just gone to
bed and like 10 minutes later he calls
me he barely has been
knocking at my door oh he's such a good
guy and his girlfriend is super sweet
that's awesome and that's cool
rice gum used didn't he was like a rock
star something he's one of your songs
and his response yeah with the with the
money counter yes yeah yeah she's good
his lawyers on them yeah Jake Paul
there's a god that guy is like so drama
prone man
like there's this new beef where the
Martinez twins with these twink little
Spanish boys okay yeah a spicy little
twinks oh god I'd like to get them both
together in a dark room behind a curtain
a couple ladders probably probably their
house a couple ladders in the garage but
apparently he was like bowling them or
some she he called them be nurse or
something damn I was like I was like
they're not even Mexican idiot they're
Spanish that's crazy that's crazy you
hit me up recently jakey yeah I think so
he said sorry if I offended you and I
said hey man it's all good
would they be offended like when we did
the blood whenever he I guess when he
came to my house oh okay that's nice but
it was a very I felt like it was a very
heartfelt apology and I said okay that's
good that's nice creig's definitely
crazy [ __ ] going on oh yeah that guy
can't get although his brother Logan
it's like super start I went to Dubai
you I should pull all that crazy crazy I
feel weird watching those I don't know
why cuz it's all a bunch of kids and the
way he just walks up there and he's like
I know you all love me good I know like
he doesn't he doesn't have any
discernible talent like he's not singing
he's not dancing no dope what did I say
singing singing he's he's not singing
he's dancing no none of those things but
he just walks out there he's got no
skill he's just like hey I'm a guy on a
stage and everyone's just like oh
touch my stop short with me and he just
he loves it it's weird how willing he is
to accept all the pubescent love do you
know what I mean he'll it's pretty weird
it's bro great Teen Mania teen me it's a
weird phenomenon I got the sense that
they bust some kids in from Dubai
funding on us really yes to here no
because he did the world's largest fan
meet right in Dubai and there was like
10,000 screaming adolescents there but
the whole thing was feel like no kids
live in Dubai I feel like it's all like
older ballers yeah it's just ballers and
slaves in like big-ass bottles of vodka
like this [ __ ] giant towers that
those are the children's little big
vodka bottles in like a stroller there
no I want to go though it seems super
fun
I'm scared there they don't [ __ ] around
they're like hardcore theocracy you know
if you stare at a lady wrong or so show
too much shoulder there they'll put you
in an unmarked grave in an unmarked
grave what did I say I thought she said
Audemars grave because it's be very
bothered they're gonna ice your grave
out but you know that's the problem
I don't know I'm where I'm weird about
Dubai cause like they legitimately have
slave laborers there because they bring
in from Asian countries reportedly they
steal their passport and don't let them
leave and like building the what's the
name of that giant building the Porsche
whatever I don't know but is that the
building that's in the clouds yeah it's
the tallest building the world by far
that's [ __ ] crazy
and so like thousands of immigrant
workers died building that thing like
[ __ ] just words of people dying
there's literally you know when you
think of medieval castles like schools
and bodies other day yeah that's what
that is or something like crazy they
just leave him there too it's really
weird leave them there yeah they're just
bodies that oh in medieval times no
that's at the boars it's crazy
is there any way no there's not graves
are I status [ __ ] though I'm ashamed for
you
they're building like artificial islands
see it's crazy over there man they have
like an island shaped like a palm tree
I wonder if someday they'd just go broke
and it's like the ultimate ghost town
just like the weirdest ghost town it
like isn't it the richest place I think
so yeah
they're killing it'd be fun yeah it
would be fun to go there I am
legitimately scared those guys don't
have like we get to fight Emirates to
get it and get like a whole room exactly
hot shower that's nice yeah let's switch
it up here let's let's lighten it up
here bit oh my god let's switch off of
unmarked graves and get right into the
goofs that sound like a diarrhea from
real it is you can see she looks over
like [ __ ] this [ __ ] will not ruin my
day I love in her face like her mouth is
watering like the minister oh I hate
that feeling
do you puke a lot no I don't puke a lot
but I you know what I'm gonna puke yeah
I peek readily yeah I mean you know when
like yeah I'm sensitive guy emotionally
and physically but that feeling when the
water starts building up yeah like a
jolly rancher you're like [ __ ] you know
what's happening I'm gonna have to throw
up
I wasn't puked he's never puked yeah in
your life mm-hmm even as a baby well
that she knows of okay because that's
like like semi-pro you see that movie no
like you never puked in your life
doctors were amazed is Will Ferrell and
frankly it to me it's concerning I
remember once in college you were super
drunk and you felt really sick and I was
worried about you and I was like to just
puke and she's like I can't puke
yeah that's why I started shoving
fingers down her throat to make her puke
we were at her friend's house and we
went in the bathroom together
lock the door people are like oh they're
probably [ __ ] I'm shoving my fingers
down her throat trying to make her puke
she she'd wanna puke and my all my time
no you've never puke it's concern yeah
that's crazy you probably have a lot of
toxins I don't know and I've gotten
drunk to the point of like blacking out
right you know crazy when HeLa gets
really drunk now it doesn't happen that
often but like in New York because the
last time I got super drunk I blacked
out and was pretty scary it was
horrifying Kerry yard yeah in New York
we were hanging out with John and we
were drinking this like sailor gin like
50% alcohol yard so we were hitting that
we got we did like three shots and
that's it oh yeah
done and so she's blocked out she can't
even stand I carry her up the reef
flights the stairs I'm I'm worried about
her I put her in the bed and because I
know she can't puke she's just digesting
at all and so I'm not sleeping I just
keep checking her pulsing [ __ ] right you
ever is that ever happen you someone's
so drunk
next to in the bed and you're like I
hope no okay a unique experience I just
wake up to it if anything yeah but last
time I threw it wasn't Iceland oh I woke
up and I threw up all over the bed Oh
like literally all over the bed and it
was it was nasty so you had puked and
passed out and then woke up no I I woke
up I passed out woke up and then threw
up and in the middle and I packed it up
like Santa's like sack the bad boys yeah
this barf
yeah throwing up sucks ass I hate it I
didn't throw up once on tour nice this
time
good job yeah I wanted to but I have a
couple of times you wanted real wood all
right we've got one commercial coming up
let's go there and we'll get back we got
so much to talk about Patrice what is he
up to
there's ghosts gasps boobs laughs ahead
don't go away we will be right back
and next we've got tri wink you've got
to try wink that's their that's their
domain try wink calm /h three guys let
me give you a task pick out a wine that
you're gonna love but here's a catch it
has to be one that you haven't had
before where would you start well let me
give you a lead introducing wink
spelled WI and C week makes it easy to
discover great wine because wink wine
experts select wines match to your taste
personalized for you ship right to your
door and starting at just $13 a bottle
there's nothing like coming home to a
box of delicious wink wine selected just
for you it's the best day of your month
that's damn it's a rough rough month
just like [ __ ] I cannot wait to get home
and just crack open that one bottle of
wine hopefully III I do hope that you
have other highlights of your month but
this is gonna be one of them
just fill out wink this is my favorite
part of this product you go on their
website they have a palette profile quiz
he answers some simple questions then
average your score your store clerk
wouldn't ask or translate into a
recommendations questions like how do
you take your coffee how do you feel
about blueberries how do you feel about
your mom they get in your head they
don't actually have that on there but
wouldn't that be interesting then wink
sends wine curated to your taste the
more wine you rate the more personalized
your monthly selection each month there
are new delicious wines like the
insanely popular summer water rose a can
you say rose a rose a can I get a way
out to my Rosie's out there thank you
there's number there's no membership fee
required you can skip any month and
cancel anytime
shipping is complimentary and if you
don't like a bottle they send you
they'll replace it with a bottle you'll
love no questions asked discover great
wine today go to try wink calm /h though
you get 20 bucks off your first shipment
that's t ry wi and c.com /h Sleaford
20 bucks off try wig comp /h 3 thank you
so graciously for your support god bless
you
and finally you know um you love um
Bethesda they make the best games and
this one's no exception I'm talking
about Elder Scrolls legends it's a card
game it's an online card game you could
play against people you could play
against AI you could play against
yourself for pizza sake it's got it all
it's free to play it's out on everything
Steam Mac iOS Android tablet phones
coming out November 30th they've got 50
new cards and 15 plus hours of new story
content coming out this month if you're
a fan of card games you have to play but
as does Elder Scrolls legends okay
go make a Bethesda dot net account and
it works across all devices even if you
disconnect you can pick it up and play
on another device I love that oh I'm on
my computer Oh God
meteor hit my house and blew up my
computer off I'm at Grandma's house so
now I'm on my phone I don't care about
anything else it was in my house only my
Bethesda account which lives eternally
and uh in the singularity cloud all of
our personalities will be uploaded there
someday and I won't ever have to leave
my house high-five right Ella twitch
drops here's a cool thing if you're
watching somebody play on twitch this
game and you're logged in you can get
free items by watching them stream oh my
god the future is now I'm halfway up to
being beamed up to the singularity in
the sky unique features we've got Lane
systems monthly updates frequent
metagame patches new cards every month
please runes prophecies color
attributions ah learn about yourself go
there and make an account at Bethesda
dotnet my friends you got PvE arenas
yeah if you like card games give it a
shot
Thank You Bethesda Elder Scrolls legends
for sponsoring us thank you to all our
sponsors if you're in the market for any
of that consider supporting our show by
supporting our sponsors thank you so
much let's
get back right into it shall we welcome
back everybody the HD podcast here with
post Malone and more puking memes we're
just doing play-by-play here if you
haven't really finished analyze that's
the look right there look at her face
right here the blonde in the back and
your best friend I just want to see the
aftermath did the husband look look look
over go back let's see if the husband's
just locked in here let's do a slaughter
you know what let's do a play-by-play
here let's let's kick it off to a
quarter speed and let's do a really slow
motion here there's a lot going on to
break down uh the girl on the right
she's feeling it she's hoping in her
mind she's like she's like please no not
like this not like this I love you Becky
but I have to puke right now out of any
time it could be it's happening oh my
god
nice little projectile and then on the
left I love her the bride is like [ __ ]
not today not today
that's crazy I admire her a building to
just swing back don't be like yeah it
took her like two one second and now
she's like nope my vows must continue
lovely she was still looking at it
saying the vows love will overcome days
our love is stronger than one puke way
stronger than one singular puke they'll
be they'll have a happy that's crazy so
then in the spirit of more pee I have
another puking video this one let's
start normal speed and we'll slow down
Timo Herriman that door Gomez de la
política Savio don't look at that face
he knows you oh my god what did you do
last night you [ __ ] weirdo bro his
eyes and [ __ ]
what looks the best is there's a
countdown on the back so this could have
been the end of the interview good guy
so this guy is first rodeo
he puked like huge like a lot in his
mouth and I swallowed it back down from
whence you came
demon you're right probably fighting off
I want to see how that woman reacted I
feel ridiculousness or something
let's go down a quarter speed oh man
life before your eyes
eight more days you remember when you
were a kid ups once it apartments for
everyone laughs to you seven you're
still here I can't believe it's
happening again
six not like this he's a machine
he's machine five more seconds ago not
only did he puke and swallow it he
immediately finishes it what you nothing
happen nothing to see here folks I gotta
see her face this is showing I hope so
see like it's these don't give enough
backs yeah they were anticipating the
puke swallows they just sign off I like
that one a lot that's a good one that's
a really good one I don't think that I
could ever swallow my own puke I I've
done it a little bit in it like to hold
it back no like a bourbon oh yeah yeah
but immediately yeah I've been there and
that we know how bad it is right but
imaginal oh yeah you know what God for
what's
better swallowing it or spitting it out
on the stage spitting it out there's
more taking a full load I was gonna say
I hope God gives me the strength to
swallow my own puke when the moment
comes I mean quick reaction time on him
somewhere somewhere I wish the minister
had that willpower mmm just swallow it
down you know she stole the show that
was a more appropriate time to smoke I
wish had more puking video that's all of
God you just threw up in front of God
God's like did on my doorstep the
threshold when she dies and she's at the
pearly gates Paul's gonna be like you
think I didn't [ __ ] see that [ __ ]
didn't allow pukers up here you gotta
wonder why though why did they both
throw up what's the react I don't fit
was nerves or a rough night the night
before I think for him it was nerd
nerves nerds there's a difference
yeah his just kind of came up heard you
could see the water you know all right
she probably went man
that explains the bride's reaction in a
way because she was partying with her
the night before and she's like Becky
don't [ __ ] you [ __ ] you're getting
married and I'm single yeah I never get
married
nobody loves me Becky you're gonna find
a nice guy next day pukes guess what now
she not get fun it's like to be one of
these people in these videos people
hanger oh you mean like that's your only
claim to fame right that beef mmm really
but I mean think about like the dating
life for them like by the way getting
into this relationship I want you to
know there's a video of you throwing up
it says live Minister [ __ ] wedding it
says if you did porn
big thing
you fight someone's like dude I want to
put your girlfriend like what she doing
porn like no she's growing up you
betrayed my trust by not telling me
about that video I'm so glad I'm not
single you got to worry about your
prospective girlfriend being in puke
videos okay
let me let me let me ask you this is a
real tone change okay but I you you were
close friends with little people yeah
yeah that was sad man yeah that was
[ __ ] up I met him in in London and
he's such a [ __ ] good dude and he was
really he was really like such a good
guy such a talented [ __ ] dude and he
was gonna [ __ ] change music for
[ __ ] ever and it socks dude it sucks
I saw that video of him like his last
video of him what does an ex OH his
friend was recording did you see that I
was I didn't want to watch it it sucks
it's [ __ ] sad his friend was
recording that huh it sucks
it's [ __ ] trashed it's where people
were saying that he committed suicide
but I didn't see that at all he just
seems like he took too many xanax no no
it was caught with something he was
laced with something with fentanyl and
the girl who gave it to him is in
custody I guess what so so there was
like foul play I don't know but I mean
[ __ ] anybody can go and buy a pill press
yeah Wow 25 bucks crazy it's [ __ ] it's
[ __ ] I [ __ ] love that kid man sucks
ass rip really cool thing man like rip
blow people [ __ ] [ __ ] I mean I think
in a way it's important that people
realize how dangerous that [ __ ] is well
here's the whole here's my whole issue
and I think it's [ __ ] up that
he literally had just passed and all the
people on the internet on Twitter and
[ __ ] we're like here kids this is an
example stop [ __ ] glorifying drugs
and [ __ ] right hip hop and [ __ ] but
it's not like anybody asked to to get
hooked on [ __ ] and you know be have you
know issues within yourself that
something makes you feel better and you
can't help it
so the student just [ __ ] died and
everybody takes it as a as a prime
opportunity to to shame people who may
have issues with drugs well instead of
supporting them like saying it's gonna
be alright like we'll figure this out
mmm and I think that's what the
fucked-up part is that's a really good
point that's what we always talk about
addiction as well is that like it
doesn't just take a drug right and you
can try a drug and you'll be fine you
don't get addicted immediately it's you
gotta have really that's what like if
you if you this is extreme example but
if you shoot up heroin once your life is
ruined and it's like well you don't you
don't generally get addicted to drugs
unless you have something underneath
that your treat you're medicating
yourself for right I think that's a very
it's a very wise way to think about it I
think I just think it's fun he's gonna
[ __ ] change it I mean [ __ ] but sucks
he's a good guy sucks ass rip for real
[ __ ] you pour out what yeah you brought
a little beer for it
just look up for your computers in
remotes in label machine in can you come
clean up this mess please I'm kidding
you can leave it on the table in spirit
alright let's watch some more videos
yeah it's a it's a downer it's hard to
talk about this I think like I only knew
him for a little bit but mmm
more than what like a genuine good real
true person that he was his music was
was gonna change like the culture of
everything like already shifting culture
in such a short like period of time that
you know he was you know like kind of on
I guess and but he's just an incredible
talented dude and good guy
I was watching videos him on stage he
was good man like yeah [ __ ] fantastic
you know I said okay whatever I don't
wanna get too deep into it but rip yeah
probably I'll leave with what you said I
think that was that was very wise
because you're never gonna stop drug
addiction you give the treat you have to
it's a dollar for the person yeah it's
everybody situation is different
mm-hm and you know say like why would
you [ __ ] like he just died like a kid
just died and this is your this is when
you choose to shame people who may or
may not use drugs you know what I mean
it's just it's [ __ ]
people are [ __ ] I think people are
pieces of [ __ ] I think they they mean
well in it they're just like they're
just stupid they mean well you know
because you don't you don't generally
think about xanax is like a dangerous
drug although I guess it is starting to
me yeah you know prescriptions yeah I
mean there's an epidemic now
prescription drugs are [ __ ] killing
people but I don't know if it wasn't
that'd be something else people got
problems they take it yeah you right
it's all it's all the person I mean like
people like I had I had a struggle like
whenever I first came out here and it is
[ __ ] I didn't have any money I didn't
have nothing and I would just [ __ ]
get weird like do crazy [ __ ] and drink
and [ __ ] two xan's and [ __ ] and I
don't do it anymore because I realized
that it's not a good path but like if
someone was there you know instead to
[ __ ] shame me but you know be there
like as a friend
you know I just wish more people were
like that instead of thinking like they
know it all you know what I mean
it's so easy to say oh you should do
this this is bad but it's not fair for
you to say that because you don't know
what someone's going through you know
what I mean for sure yeah that's how I
feel cool
got any memes dude I got memes for days
man I'm a broker mean broker kind of
memes means I got one on deck here have
you heard of Elsa gate mmm-hmm this kind
of it like annoyed me a little bit okay
because I've been talking about this
[ __ ] for so long how kids channels are
sick depraved garbage on YouTube why
doesn't the Wall Street Journal write
about that [ __ ] I think they know okay
but I've been taught I've made so many
videos about this over the time and now
everyone is like yo h3 you need to make
another Elsa video and it's like feel
like I'm just beating a dead horse right
at this point but now the media is
starting to pick up pick up on it and
people have been dating there's like a
subreddit lcj and people have been
digging into some [ __ ] weird really
weird [ __ ] like it sweeter well it's
always been weird but let me show you
some of these like thumbnails oh so this
is a popular kids show look at this
thumb up so here's one called
Elsa and Peter missunderstand eating
[ __ ] and in the thumbnail these kids are
eating [ __ ] out of the toilet eating
[ __ ] it's the name of the video this is
monetized yes probably it was on the
kids app bike I imagine I mean has 134
thousand views Elsa's forced slavery and
club strippers and they're crying on a
stripper pole
half a million views from one month ago
this one like let me explain how the
YouTube algorithm works these videos in
general but it's specifically these kids
videos and do not get like these
channels either the videos have like 500
views or millions right and it just
depends on if the algorithm picks it up
and promotes it because these kids sit
on their tablets and it's just scroll
auto place through videos all day
okay well S&M one so this one this S&M
one has six point million views in two
weeks
that's cool though that means most
likely it was mom ties and it definitely
means it was heavily promoted by YouTube
and here is a girl with a web a dude in
a speedo being basically dominated by it
like a dominatrix and a crying girl with
wagga money what the [ __ ] and then to
the right of it revenge hypnosis is a
she has her on a leash and she's
crawling around like it's just weird
and so it's just strange it's stuck it's
weird and it's sexual here's one where
the kids are drinking piss that kids
peeing they're just I think well look at
this they're abducting this girl that's
on the bottom left you have Mickey Mouse
Mickey and Minnie Mouse what there's
there's a girl gagged and taped and
bound and they're abducting her eight
hundred twenty thousand views and then
to the right of it is spider-man with a
stiletto fetish being stepped on by
Elsa's stilettos so these are all
reminiscent of really dark weird porn
fetishes they're real what the [ __ ] and
so people are theorizing that this [ __ ]
is all run and somewhat of a front buff
for actual pedophilia rings we're real a
child sex rings or whatever right so
there's some it not correct there's not
really really good evidence but there's
some compelling stuff though yeah here
I'll show this [ __ ] gets really weird
but I mean these thumbnails is enough
this is weird because you you wouldn't
make these thumbnails and put it on
unless you were trying weird to be sick
yeah this is an accident you know this
isn't made by a full-grown person yeah
this is a legit business you're
animating yeah yes they're putting a lot
of resources these are grown these are
adults making this and a big operation
so let me pull up some of those yeah
here's a comment from one of these
videos this [ __ ] is honestly pretty
disturbing here guys make the episode
that she is all naked will be banned
yeah so there so okay that that one's
not that weird let me show you
we'll be Ben Warren Rushmore back real
are the ones are Russian so this [ __ ]
so somebody links a moment from the
video and at that time stamp according
to this person I haven't clicked it the
little girl is shown touching herself
between the legs in the comments they
linked to that moment and the guy says
I'm glad someone else knows that too
smiley face she does it at two so sweet
I could help her out with that for sure
a tongue could do her so well so these
are the these are not kids watching this
[ __ ] these are [ __ ] creeps and
there's there's whole genres with
millions of views on YouTube of little
girls first of all this is there's
nothing wrong with a kid in a bathing
suit right but sometimes there's these
channels where they're in skimpy little
bathing suits and there seems like
they're making kid content real kids
yeah for kids and it's like innocent
enough but then you see you're like who
is actually watching this [ __ ] I'm sure
some kids are but when you see comments
like this you're like what the [ __ ] we
are what those are actually going on
here right what this is [ __ ] crazy
there's a lot more there's uh yeah here
let me go let me go you the Elsa gates
subreddit and show you the top post
there well let's go down the meme hole
on this one so let me sort by top of all
time here yeah it's it's it's super
super disturbing stuff so we looked at
that one drinking beer
so this one is coded gibberish comments
so these guys when you go to these
videos you'll see that there's just a
bunch of gibberish typed out like Oh
half the comas are all gibberish and the
explanation you frequently hear is like
it's just kids slamming the keyboard and
it's just total nonsense comment yeah I
read perfect English can't really write
it even though I can read it and
understand like some words I'm just
gonna well comment and then it's like
two-year-old who's just pushing buttons
that's what I can say right and so this
guy theorized that there are codes for
example here's an example of a common I
found on one of the colors videos when
type manga into a virtual tied keyboard
emulator tie symbols appear instead of
English letters and you can got a
sentence and tie that is able to be
translated for example this shows up
like this that goat says I have to go to
bed okay that's just an example it's
crazy so here you go down let's see here
there was one over here was in the
comments so here this guy did this one
on this comment it's just total
gibberish right if you remove the
garbage it says see you soon parking lot
bring her what the [ __ ] what okay so
what this guy did is he took out a bunch
of the stuff see you soon and the
parking lot bring her yikes that's crazy
so like man let's see there's all kinds
of articles about it now and then this
is fair there's one of the posters don't
let Elsa gate become pizza gate he's
saying like let's not get carried away
right because there's probably a problem
here let's not divulging the total
conspiracy theory but and then like look
at this [ __ ] this is all different
channels thumbnails they're all the same
[ __ ] of this clip of drinking piss so
they think that there's actually one
huge organization that would make sense
it's exactly the same stuff look at this
yeah that's Chris about twenty or thirty
thumbnails here which are all
derivatives of the same same format
there's a wall one dudes peeing in it
the other person is drinking on the
other side but they're technically from
different channels yes they're all
different channels according to this
post I mean there is a phenomenon
YouTube where people always steal
thumbnails like right but I mean this
weird look how similar it is yeah same
wall I've seen so I'm planning I'm
actually planning a video about this and
I don't there's videos the Russian shits
the weirdest there's this phenomenon we
made a video about a while ago where
this guy had needles and he was
injecting a baby doll there's a whole
weird fetish questions the weird guy but
I mean glove Garneau with someone else
but on Russian YouTube you'll find
videos with MIT like tens of millions of
views of people role playing with the
real kids and giving them real
injections and they're screaming and
crying and they're strapped down and
they're injecting their bare ass real
kids yes real kids I just you know
whether this shit's true or not I set it
on Twitter it's like our new video got D
monetized immediately it had a little
side boob on it and I blurted out I
painstakingly blurred every detail out
and it was immediately demonetised
they're like d monetizing all tv-ma
content and meanwhile the [ __ ] they're
showing the kids is the most depraved
[ __ ] I've ever seen you gotta emphasize
that it was do monetized after they
reviewed it right it's not yeah everyone
thinks like well wait for them to review
I uploaded it 24 hours ahead of time it
was demonetized I requested a manual
review and they Dumont yeah they cut the
montage but new one yeah one that we
just supposed to do I'll be the judge of
that
yeah yeah yeah you'd be the judge of
that tell me what you think about that
anyway what the [ __ ] I'm gonna go I'm
gonna go down deeper down that rabbit
hole in our upcoming video thank you
sure it's crazy it's there's there it's
probably mostly just weird
garbage but there's some percentage
hiding within the normal [ __ ] that is
doing some weird
I think we're gravy creepy [ __ ] if it's
one organization that's crazy
it's gotta be I think people are so sick
how do you [ __ ] like
it's [ __ ] weird how do you what's
wrong with people man like I feel like
more than ever I'm so disillusioned like
this whole Harvey Weinstein thing right
like this guy's straight up raping
people for decades and he's just like oh
I'm gonna go to my job the next tomorrow
and and make a movie and not even like
worry about it and every 10 minutes
there's a new one of someone else I'm
getting like fatigued I'm getting sex
offender fatigue it's crazy
wearing a [ __ ] crazy place have you a
weird stories the things you've seen um
I feel like I'm not high level enough
mm-hmm right once you get to that like
jay-z pool party [ __ ] something like
that jay-z is probably good but there's
some weirdos any Patrice updates okay it
doesn't rotate anymore who's how you
should see if anybody can like super
sleuth that look in the comments see but
yeah yeah see if do we have questions
let's take a call let me take a call
know whose house that is okay cool I'm
gonna take a call we have got on the
line saying that he was showing like a
shower too I got I'm the lizard yeah on
the stream hold on one sec let's touch
that after we take this call from I am
The Lizard King what okay yep yo but I
that's good wait wait so my question is
for post e okay so what is something you
wish someone told you before you joined
the music industry um I don't know I
wish somebody told me how much work it
was gonna be like yeah yeah you know
it's like my favorite thing you know is
being in the studio and everything and
that's at that point it doesn't even
feel like a job but you know whenever
you're going around doing promo and like
you know meeting and greeting you know
everybody from different companies
different everything that's the part
where it gets exhaust all the other
yeah and it's just I wish somebody told
me how much interviews suck because it's
like you know they ask you the same
questions over and over again I hate
that yeah I mean not that experience
that but I hate repeating right yeah you
know and you try to come up with a
different answer every time but at the
end of the story yeah yeah yeah it's
like dude just be like everybody I just
had this interview with this other guy
just go watch that we're good yeah
exactly as I say video yeah just not say
anything in the show video about my
answers oh my god that's yeah I bet you
there's so much extra [ __ ] yeah it's a
lot what's to stop you from just being
like no more press I'm just going to see
already got that really yeah after the
tour I'm locked off I'm here you gotta
focus on your craft at some point I have
to finish my album yeah everyone's
waiting for the beer bongs mentally I'm
ready Rock coming by gonna be done I'm
gonna finish it this week really is it
gonna be out this week no be out
December you got to do some posts on
December 1st at midnight that'd be
insane viral marketing yeah it was all
me the whole time
here's one I got Facebook is listening
okay first of all let me preface this by
saying one as you all know I despise
Facebook I think they are the Antichrist
an evil company they're run by
sociopaths Mark Zuckerberg er is a
sweater wearing [ __ ] robotic look at
me doing human things right there's that
one video of him and everyone's got VR
goggles on I think we washed it together
maybe what pull this up before Mark but
Artie this video beer demo yeah where's
this [ __ ] he's like
oh this [ __ ] is funny this isn't what I
was looking for but it's great okay
there's this AI news channels that just
auto-generate news clips with AI voices
and other B staffers pulled off on
Tuesday I don't care with the Red Cross
right so we're gonna partner up with
right let's okay just explain the video
anyway it doesn't matter it's hard to
explain but this this one we're about to
watch and just by the title of the video
I already know that it's real because it
just happened like what happened you so
I ordered I ordered this thing is
listening to us all the time yeah but I
a bunch of stuff from 511 and they make
like tactical clothes the great brand
very cool stuff and I was talking about
it like oh I'm so excited to get my five
eleven stuff around Ben who is my
assistant and it's like next day he gets
an advertisement for 511 I mean I'm
trying to do it with four-wheelers I
want to buy a four-wheel right so this
is exactly what this guy's showing and
his finish it and Facebook is so [ __ ]
creepy like they know no boundaries like
as a company I think they're artistic I
know they're the people who run an
artistic artistic and they don't
understand like what's not right like
just having your phone to listen to
people without telling them so you can
honor them and she's not rightly so now
don't understand that watch this [ __ ] by
the way take this with a grain of salt
because there there's no definitive
proof in this video but it is compelling
definitely happens to me is my wife it's
not surprising for sure so here have a
look and we think Facebook is listening
to us and taking key words from our
conversations and then putting in
suggested ads through Facebook
pulling funny like when I do a test here
nice camera and oh yeah nice nice I be
the ugly [ __ ] cat my favorite genre of
oblivion cats
we never search for cats especially cat
food let's find out
alright so all day we are going to be
talking about cat food because I could
use some cat food well the cat is almost
out of food so we might need some cat
food we should buy some captain I went
to into it the wife roleplay you're
having a lot of fun and ask if they know
where to get cat food and there you have
it
cat food it's not the most scientific
well they got to do another by the way
this came in two days later so that's
what I found interesting two days later
oh no it doesn't happen immediately cuz
it's too obvious that the same thing
happened to me I can't remember what it
was but there was a certain item that we
were like talking about and then I got
an ad for it and I never typed it in yep
I never looked it up I think it's the
Alexa does that - they call the Alexa
the Amazon did you get rid of it yeah
you know it's only kitchen counter but
I'm pretty sure that [ __ ] eavesdrops on
yes well how would she know if you say
Alexa right she's got to have a constant
stream of listening what they don't tell
you that they send that data back to
their servers gotta be I mean you know
like we're just hanging out in the
living room and in the other completely
other room and then she just goes I'm
sorry I didn't get that really yeah
that's happened several times I keep
around though very convenient one time
it was really creepy we were just having
a random conversation never said
anything that sounded like
like so and then all of a sudden she was
like I'm sorry I didn't understand that
she's not I'm sorry I wasn't talking to
you sorry
she never apologized so anyway I hate
Facebook they're they're just evil
they're awful I want to erase facebook
straight up I'm so over it
here's one of the founding members of
Facebook what did he do exactly
this guy I think it started you think
they had plans for it do we like this or
do you think it was well that's to just
be like this video addresses exactly
that question really okay this guy Sean
Parker who was the former president of
Facebook and he quit with a guilty
conscience this guy ran Facebook listen
to him talk about it you know if the if
the thought process that went into
building these applications Facebook
being the first of them to really
understand it that thought process was
all about how do we consume as much of
your time and conscious attention as
possible and that means that we need to
sort of give you a little dopamine hit
every once in a while because someone
liked or commented on a photo we're a
post or whatever and that's going to get
you to contribute more content and
that's gonna get you you know more likes
and comments it's a it's a valid it's a
social validation feedback loop that
that it's like I mean it's exactly the
kind of thing that a that a hacker like
myself would come up with because you're
like that it's a self-proclaimed anchor
a hacker like myself did I have best
faith that dude hacks you have
carbo-loading a vulnerability in in
human psychology and I just I think they
just you know we the inventors creators
you know and it's it's me it's mark it's
the you know Kevin Systrom and Instagram
it's all of these people understood this
consciously and we did it anyway so a
one had the guy so bastard Batory
and
a acknowledgment of that you're right
you know the founders me these other
guys were brilliant and we understood
that and we saw it I mean on one hand my
reaction is like obviously but on the
other hand what is he implying he's
saying that the Facebook feed is
intentionally built to manipulate
people's mood right
so if nobody's liked your [ __ ] in a day
they're like I want this person stayed
hooked so they'll show your post this is
what I'm guessing from what he said
they'll keep showing your post to people
that they know you care about always at
the top of your feet until it you get
that like that dopamine that keeps you
coming back right so it's not like a
democratic process they're they're [ __ ]
they're intentionally [ __ ] with
people they're kind of creepy
I think it is creepy you think that when
you would scroll down your feet it's
like just chronological what people
posted and way it used to be it's just
it really did that's why I actually
liked Facebook back in the day it was
chronological and you felt like you were
current you understood what was
happening but now it's just a nightmare
Facebook yeah it's yeah it's like to get
you know people hooked like he said like
you want you want to be validated he
said you know by your peers right so
like if you think something is cool and
you post it and then you get a like
you're like oh okay cool God we're
friends he said later or I saw I read in
a news report people spend on average 50
minutes a day on Facebook Facebook users
and then nuts that's a lot more really
yeah right on average I guess I don't
know pressure even I probably spend 10
minutes a day and I don't [ __ ] with my
girlfriend spends a long time not on
Facebook but on Twitter Instagram a long
time I like Twitter Instagram I like
Twitter a lot I love both of them for
different reasons but twitter twitter
there's nothing there there's no
[ __ ] it's just it is chronological
as far as I can tell right it's just
people talking yeah people being people
people have been people great memes it's
just it's not transparent like
gone illogical yeah it's but what what's
really popular it's not so up to them I
hate that I know I think someone doesn't
like you guys at YouTube
I mean we've long suspected that I think
a lot of people there do like us
I think the upper upper management there
hates us because they see us as anti
social justice warrior reactionists they
see us as dangerous not I don't think
there's so much concern about us being a
threat to the platform because we talk
about it I think it's a political thing
I think I honestly think it's an
ideological how are you threat to the
platform it doesn't make any [ __ ]
sense because we always talk [ __ ] about
YouTube and poke holes then I'm gonna
watch what can you do anyways I smoking
cigarettes is bad for you people so I'm
saying I don't think that that's what
threatens them it's the ideology of us
making fun of like social justice
warriors which they need it's weird
I did but I genuinely think that's what
it is that that they hate about us do
you agree you know it's a shame because
I'm a very liberal leftist person and
and I feel like on the left is a little
political you don't have to get involved
but the left is like and realizing
itself and it's sick like the super far
left radicals they cannibalizing their
own political allies you know just
because I don't think some entitled
[ __ ] xarna should be able to harass
humungus right no I started noticing her
channel [ __ ] with after that whole
humongous thing we made a couple of like
anti social justice worries we didn't
that's when I noticed it our channel
getting [ __ ] right hmm anyway let's
what see this you're gonna love you're
gonna you are gonna absolutely lose your
[ __ ]
at this video this one's called reek
reclaiming the armrest and this guy's a
total legend right now let me start from
the beginning because it is an important
sentence here what up Facebook's you
know we're in some [ __ ] [ __ ] now buy a
good stuff get ready
what's up Facebook's bathroom right now
in an airplane and I have a guy sitting
next to me that thinks he owns the
armrest I'm gonna go back and I'm gonna
try to get some video of me showing that
if he wants that tussle with the muscle
hopefully I get it on camera this guy's
about the tussle with the muscle boy
bump mom this is these this is Facebook
names he does CrossFit too by the way
why'd he do it so aggressively hold on
is he strong kind of make up facebook
video I mean does CrossFit exactly
[Music]
we just testable with the muscle buddy
you just tested with the muscle my dog
that's crazy
he did I mean that's kind of the
reaction that I would have yeah it's not
anything to fight over like nothing
really yeah
what the wall I mean when you tussle
with the muscle yeah you're gonna get it
yeah yeah that's a good fantastic really
um here this one what up Facebook's I
need all my videos with that now okay I
love how Facebook is now like an
individual like there's a bunch of love
y'all out there oh you're looking at my
facebook I love Facebook's
follow that guy he seems like a laser in
the real legend he seems like a cool dad
right yeah very cool dad I love cool dad
memes
any news it's for the camera me there
you guys I was working through that my
head I was talking this this next video
goes out to everybody who hates their
job okay because as much as you hate
your job it could be worse just remember
that and that I feel bad for whoever's
job this is because a parent record it's
what I just said this is as bad as it
gets
okay no oh my god that's not full screen
I want to go now this video doesn't go
anywhere
this is it imagine it's Monday 8:30 a.m.
you drag your ass out you got a cup of
coffee you're getting paid minimum wage
probably maybe a little bit over just
pumps it through the soul crush and you
have to confront these up heat-seeking
[ __ ] and then they say steel
looks like a case of the Mondays whole
office fish joke like this
there's workplaces like this I would
probably uh I think I'm good so no
matter who you are wherever you work it
could be worse I cannot thank you to me
that's how I just don't think songs
belong in the workplace maybe later
maybe later in the evening right and you
know that's Monday I could just I know
that's Monday morning god that's what I
was thinking let me pull that up let me
pull up that Walmart chant this shit's
gonna [ __ ] your life up Austin no matter
how however sick of the [ __ ] you are in
your life just imagine it's Monday
morning 8:00 a.m. you're in Walmart and
your boss does this making 650 an hour
and he says you have that well you have
to participate and stomp your feet
Austin or your fire hang up reminds me a
minute like race would he call that not
seen before the minutes rage start
freaking out I just read it's a great
book
[Music]
little flies great book it's like one of
those like that you would never plan on
reading it but it's it they make you
read for a reason yeah it's a good thing
like I would never read those books but
I looking back I'm like I was enriched
my soul I never read that one read that
I had no there's like a scene where you
get some prostitute just talks to isn't
there some meme about like people
there's been serial killers two separate
ones that were found with Catcher in the
Rye in their back pocket
really can you research that he entered
an do some research on serial killers
and catch her in the right anyway sorry
I was having so much wrong it just goes
on set this here alarm clock every
morning make this your alarm so that you
know your life could be worse
that's my life advice you know what I
really hate is it was the most cringe
eesh is whenever my teachers saying and
it's just like acapella yeah like my
teachers would sing like cute little
song and I'd be like this is really I'm
cringing don't sing right just just
don't yeah time and place for song like
I don't know it there's like they're
expecting if we're gonna be like wow
they're pretty good I like you know
you're proving yourself to me pretty
cool so the guy who murdered John Lennon
had Catcher in the Rye on really in
there is there more than one case of
what sir there was more than one wasn't
there Dan yeah the guy who shot or tried
to kill Reagan also was apprehended with
the book on him and then allegedly
Harvey Oswald according to Wikipedia but
really that's the read to presidential
assassin tip attempts and John Bull once
successful and then John Lennon who's
like even beyond presidential right
that's three catches in the right I
don't want to read that person's yes huh
well I'm fine well certainly you're not
the what I did right I definitely wasn't
paying attention that's where you yeah
it's that it's that CIA brain-scrambling
you read Catcher in the Rye then all the
sudden they're like dog poops and a
bench and then you're like must kill the
president yeah I know I mean it's not an
interesting book you would think that if
they were gonna maybe that's why they
were so enraged with the outcome of the
dilemmas [ __ ] happen yeah I read this
whole [ __ ] book we're gonna kill the
president
pretty nothing you think if they're
gonna like do some mind scrambling
tricks in a book they would do it in
like Harry Potter or something right
yeah yeah they wouldn't pick an obscure
who wrote that book Oh Dan was saying
the guy tell me more about the author
because Dan just said the guy was really
weird too Salinger what did he do jerk
off in a theater or something no he was
more just like a shut-in like he he
never did interviews and I think he he
has like dozens and dozens of other
novels that he wrote and thought they
were all crap and refused to release
them and yeah he's just he died recently
like in the last 10 years or so and and
yeah just died like completely isolated
living in the middle of nowhere in this
house the gated house would never talk
to anybody just weird guy okay I mean
that's weird
how about weird what's the gross what
how much did that book make and when was
it released let's get some research guys
come on put them to the test
here this video gave me a crack up here
peep the [ __ ]
oh do we have up another a question on
deck what do we got here we don't not
slow day so in case well he ends on the
he's the great viral it's Gordon so
everyone's like [ __ ] this guy and he's a
tough subject that he has instructed
know it works now but he's just the
Great Firewall if you guys don't get on
just know they in he was polite on the
phone and he listened to you but in his
mind he was like this guy's not good you
know I am I on the air
[Laughter]
oh yeah it's right here
you're using analysis they do the best
there's no but there's one whole montage
of just I said let me say montage Oh
c-span prank Union New Jersey good
morning the same good morning I'm a
soldier I'm served in the US Army I'm
over there in Germany and back here in
the States right now for a little while
now I have to say because all these
people that is so anti-american you know
in protest you know coming he tells it
to him they're protesting all over
Europe against this you know oh I am
feeling them is that you know I'm an
American and I can suck my own [ __ ] he's
strung him along he gave him a sense of
security is it back to back good morning
well I wish it was back i watch this
video good prank call here
[ __ ] watch this this next video gave me
a real giggle watch this goofy [ __ ] I
don't know why he's got his mic and a
mushroom in his hand I don't know how
that would ever come to be just watch
this he confuses which is the mic and
wishes the mushroom why the hell you got
a mushroom in your hand
broadcasting rule number one don't
confuse the mic with the mushroom
yeah the guy's face obviously yes know
how they work yeah you've got to plug
your mushroom in let me get it Ian can
you bring in some beers god damn it oh
that's for you do you need another beer
no I got here Cheers
oh my god we're good Ian never mind
Cheers love you glad you're here Cheers
yeah you're a weird yeah come on drink
this sorry hopefully one other one just
yell at him tough credit beer
so bring it some more beers Ian goddamn
it
what a beer it has been two hours really
sorry I was late no it's mature since we
started I know don't worry about the
same [ __ ] happens we're good
we're professionals we should have seen
our free show though what it was crazy
man I'll probably be highlights on the
internet what is it Frank for you oh
really I was like straddling the mic and
[ __ ] thank you you're scared I was that
was I took my time to have 45 seconds 30
seconds I want that there's like Stu I
was straddling the mic and [ __ ] it was a
good fest yes
oh yeah the exact same tweet every day
yeah he said we're saying come embrace
the meme too far cuz every tweet now is
just slam slams yes really well here I
showed everyone but I just noticed
wheats to be like I love you baby right
wanna be with you forever
rice no it's I want to slam you he
switched well let me show you this most
the fans are the audience has seen it
but wait go up go up tonight
Lamy raw babe is that a man that you
want to slam raw I resent a man who
wants to slam you wrong slam Iran at
dark alley Weinstein style girl girl hi
cutie hi cutie I like a girl you should
try to winning that and see how it goes
girl girl let's do like social
experiment
girl I should say hi cutie
what's the good one for me to tweet it I
should do wait I want to fly me wrong
let's all do a social experiment right
now this is a part of the show where
we're like nobody's watching let's just
[ __ ] make tweets what did you tweet
girl so I'm gonna say girl is better
than hi cutie girl just so cryptic I'll
just say girl now I can't pull off
you're like a musician your music
they'll get it music girl is weird
that's not you never said girl ela what
was the first thing he said to ela are
you like girl what did I say what was
the first day of me raw babe like
microwave motek girls what up sweetie
what up sweetheart so we agreed that hi
cutie is good for me I see what he means
it's more creepy it's better for you
it's it's more interesting for you don't
think hi cutie is [ __ ] weird to do
but it's more ah let me find a good one
hi cutie I get it come slammy Robbie I
mean and maybe a picture of him maybe I
should just completely emulate this I'm
trying to slay him tonight I'm trying to
slam tonight which we did three days in
a row
yeah we did my you down you know I love
you
when are we dating how about who's your
daddy time and place I'll be there
like slamming slamming I wanted tweet
one but my father was a gambling man Oh
what the [ __ ]
oh sorry anything yeah we need more we
need more girl memes so do we have any
like I'm trying to slam tonight it's
kind of crazy how they're all about this
obscure woman women yeah we're trying to
understand who maybe he doesn't know
that it's like a public feed maybe he
thinks he's deeming this girl no because
you think you'd at least mix it up or at
least look at your feet and say wow I
tweet about this is a refrain this girl
so much yeah she's flattered though with
every tweet he's getting closer
it's like it's like it's like [ __ ]
unlocking Darth Vader yes sorry max for
the day you got a slam every day to get
there what's my tweet come slam me raw
I'm gonna say that I'm slimy right babe
I gotta say come slimy Rob babe with
this picture no but I think I want to
say come replicate this picture what do
you think it was she knows what's up
would you like it I thought that hi
cutie I guess my because you're a singer
and it's cooler a singer they weren't
even singing sing singers a singer
singer so what a bigger thing wrong
singer singer singer singer singer
singer but say it loud your singer yeah
you see singer singer singer singer okay
it's Wow my words got the bed god forbid
my mom's happy about it
Josie we're not your words Ethan fine
mom singer I'm gonna be a singer no but
it's just that word
it's just sinker she's like make sure
you pronounce singer really singer
singer I think it's super inappropriate
[Music]
singer it's totally inappropriate I'm
not gonna brand or singer but I think I
don't know yeah so in German it says
Inger oh yeah yeah they have like very
it's very like aggressive way to say it
yeah it's like I want to kill every Jew
on this planet they say like they're
probably saying I wanted so every close
no definitely no they said so like I
would say like singer singer singer but
the Germans go sigdoc right yeah see
that's exactly what I'm saying they're
like man I wish I could so human flesh
this can of Jews please say Singha from
now on no heart are you down here it's
inappropriate people are very sensitive
these days not doing anything right I
thought you're doing hi cutie I do can I
don't know that I'm a hi cutie I don't
know if I can get away with that it's
just me why are you scared just express
yourself you think he's scared to tweet
the same tweet every day I'm slam mihrab
babe I like that one slam I can't do it
girl come slam me Robbie yeah all right
I'm not doing I'm putting now huh what
is the was the chat think it slammed a
girl
what am I can't consult with the chat
I'm trust them on anything all right
here let's move it on
let's move it on so this is what I call
a tough crowd
so yeah let's break this down in this
episode of ridiculousness
[Music]
oh good battery change will be the
living [ __ ] like he's dealing with the
hecklers in the car Midway arise with
just a good fun the guys on the stage
has got a guitar to the bus station slap
the dick out of your mouth when you're
working do
since then II waited cause he's a male
prostitute also also also shredding
while while he's talking shredding and
does a little riffs a lot now here's
when when the crowd gets ready here you
go have a good time everyone a good time
[Music]
[ __ ] axes the sky with this guitar
over that you saw him he's coming at me
folks what do you think absolutely not
no kidding show's over dumb out
it's a tough crowd it's nice cause I'm
next it's called so how to deal with
hecklers why don't one what in the
strike you're good it's all fun and
games it's great how quick it goes from
everyone's like oh he's being heckled
it's so much fun you still with a
blackberry he's got this look afterwards
like you could kill someone right now
yeah it's pretty destroyed like him
though
roxtor I'm not but it's interesting like
once the attack happened you realized
that the anger wasn't a joke like
everyone thought that frame very quick
very quickly based a lot of velocity
there I mean essentially like hitting
somebody with a guitar doesn't really
hurt I mean that's it's maybe an
electric but not an acoustic I mean
because acoustic is kind of like thinner
it's follow an electrical I killed that
one yeah that's a good point if he an
electric he would have yeah I maybe he
wouldn't have though maybe maybe that
guy was a plant just to get on the
podcast this is a long bomb yes Patrice
Allah Patrice Wilson level of planning
have we got a callin from taillow halo
way Oh what up
don't play me like that you better say
some [ __ ] I can't hear you girl oh this
is happening what's good okay so
obviously my question is proposed
anyways my question is posed last time
you're on the podcast
you mentioned the construction of a
doomsday bunker yeah I'm just wondering
have there been any developments as
construction been completed have you
picked spot yeah thank you
I'm working on I'm working on a nice
fortified area out of state somewhere
you know you know middle of middle of
America I like that your accent changed
when you started talking about it yeah a
little like country twenty two boys
middle American middle America no um
yeah we're working out we're working on
it right now I just bought a house out
there and then we're gonna start
building immediately do you think you're
invited that's nice do you think we're
getting closer or you think I like the
climate are we more likely doomsday are
we getting further from doomsday I think
I wouldn't say doomsday I would say
government what is that beer you're
afraid of like a hot like a like a
thought off my own little tips here
tired tyranny listen yeah yeah yeah
I think I think under our current
administration I don't know just
generally you don't generally generally
just a feeling of like even [ __ ]
Facebook right it's the way that the
mission is listening to us all the time
it's way creepy yeah it's just weird
well what's my new facebook facebook
facebook bots and we've watched the news
I don't think Facebook would do it I
think I think they're part of it I mean
all that data gathering I mean [ __ ] if
they'll listen to our conversations and
shove ads down our throats based off of
what we talked about
that date is definitely being [ __ ]
transferred [ __ ] and people are
listening to everything that we say and
everything's on record and I think
that's [ __ ] 1984 that's creepy it is
so creepy man
and a lot I mean a lot of people will
tell you well I didn't do anything wrong
so I have nothing to worry about
right but that's a fallacy because if
essentially if you you know one wants to
live in a [ __ ] dictatorship or a
tyrannical right
zeitgeist well anytime if you become
someone of importance that's a threat to
whatever establishment or maybe you have
someone in in power that be that thinks
of you as an enemy or wants to extort
you or blackmail you
anything you say are done could be used
against you in any way just keep my
mouth shut
it's also creepy you do handle my own
and take care of my friends you know
stock up yeah just you know four or five
be safe be safe from take make sure that
I can do what I can to make sure that
I'm safe and my friends and family are
safe that's nice but am I still what was
my position in your government me sure I
thought yeah it was like it was like you
got to write down everything that
happened in the old world
I'm the new world scribe describe yeah
that's nice that data is gonna be very
messy all right the records from that
leave tow very shaky not a lot is known
[Laughter]
I think you do a good job
Thanks preciate you a kneeler makes
ecology but that's not the culture
like who is this guy like a thousand
tracks there's apparently an a Patrice
update
is changed patterns really here's what I
think's going on there I think he's
actually there and these are live
updates that he keeps looping and so he
knows we're talking about him so he
keeps he said they're [ __ ] with the
curtain in a heartbeat pattern so I
think he's just trying to bait us a
little bit this video tickled me patient
patient cop gives drunk man every chance
to go away this time what is your
address this is like how dare you
thank you tell me that I'm not angry
this is a just trying to get deeply
right now this is like a scene out of
like some like post-apocalyptic world
wrong time to be an activist dude over
me do you mind just kind of stepping
away from it a little bit please thank
you hey Joe hey I got somebody from
detox coming to kind of talk with you a
little bit okay kind of hang out he's
taking keep an eye on the homeless
person who's actually overdosing okay
this is a literal hell on earth
that's his drunk guy comes in around
sorry could you step away from you're
about ready to be arrested you hear him
is Frank Kelly's like step away to get
away from the car I'm Washington step
away from you no no I will stand right
here on the public sidewalk and I dare
you to breathe this comes to his friends
actually now right now I'm doing with
the other gentleman here you're
hindering and delay no I'm not shaking
hands what did you say and ask
[Laughter]
[Music]
[ __ ] wait
oh I love they wrote this guy he's like
fulfilled this nightmare scenario where
the cops chase him down oh yeah that
happened mm oh wow that's the best just
dessert the cops you mean like you know
you get now ok run as fast as you can
Poli good that's that's for being a rest
put your arms out to the side you're
under
[Laughter]
and there falls a hero all day
Wow MLK and others who fought valiantly
for our civil rights
this guy this guy was um this guy he
definitely deserved to be arrested he
deserved to be arrested a long time yes
yeah how [ __ ] patient was that cop
crazy well that's all I got
there's a meme meme hole yeah we went
all the way down I mean there's a couple
things that skip through but [ __ ] then I
got one more you want more
yeah one last way Road you know Joel
Osteen remember that guy yeah you know
him from the church he was the guy for
the mega church and Houston was flooded
boy yeah and he's like oh my god I don't
want these poor people's [ __ ] dirty
shoes am i right mega church yeah so
there was this guy this was on reddit
it's a great video they got this
Joel I haven't I find it this look-alike
he looks so much like Joel Osteen I
don't know what he looks like you know a
real picture how's it for reference I'll
just pull
I was direction Joel Osteen this is OES
Tim well let's look at Joey here's Joey
Asterius not who I was looking for but
now you know who that looks like Joe
Austin or Joel [ __ ] now I'm confused
all right now I'm just straight-up
confused I dare you to judge me here
okay guys yeah I know this guy okay so
um well this [ __ ] douche bag this guy
this guy's evil so they got this
look-alike he looks so much like him by
the way Joel Osteen he sold out the was
it called the forum in LA wow that we
saw you are you there Justin Bieber did
it this mega church pastor sold out the
forum yeah that's crazy
john mayer did it like yes so this guy's
as famous as the the biggest you know
means famous people that's crazy so this
guy he looks so much like joel osteen
they go to the forum and he impersonates
him and he wants to see how deep he can
get without any tickets without any
clearance at all so here i would believe
it if I saw let me see if I can get free
parking since I'm Joel I still have to
pay even though I'm the one doing it the
forum dude let's go blessing people
that's like twenty thirty thousand seats
hey it's got less you know what kind of
guys smell that
that's guy here we go
where's Joel's entrance where's Jules
and me Joel right this way god bless you
God bless you God bless you sir good
evening well god bless gentlemen happy
to see you all out here purchasing the
book god bless you we'll see you in
there now god bless you Papa Bush ghost
Rose ghost Rose Jo hugger and Jael Baker
of course you can get right with a
couple god bless I'm looking for a beer
but they only got sodas here
god bless you ladies enjoy your meal
stay tuned he gets very very very deep
into this whole turn out right how are
you sir
thank you for such a pleasure to have
you here thank you so much for coming
out tonight thank you
so here's walking right up to the stage
essentially without any clearance any
ticket just a camera crew and a nice
pretty face and a couple of got a
[ __ ] cemetery dude all right let's
pull it up [ __ ] this dude I just saw an
ela screen he's in a cemetery it's
definitely him I saw we're gonna buy an
bracelets it was right here it's back
it's a block okay let me pull it up it's
a black man's hand
that's Patrice he's got the bracelets on
the bracelet Sun fun all right take it
what a page out of Chris's notebook he's
like man I've been wearing braces before
that kid was born he's being emboldened
by all these viewers he's gonna [ __ ]
dig up a corpse and [ __ ] it all right
come on
we're watching don't let me down I see
you in the graveyard you freak you want
to just sit here and wait for that to
expire probably the safest here that's a
cemetery that is Patrice and a senator
yeah countdown with my name in the title
I love you just that goodbye I'll spend
the night with you well I'm worried
about December 1st that's what I was on
December 1st yeah let's do a getaway I
don't want to be in LA boy cuz he's here
[ __ ] that well you let him come she's
holed up with some shot ease yeah
make a whole video about it what's the
safest room in your house there's not
it's very vulnerable and it makes me
very vulnerable and you can attack from
anywhere here he knows that if he's
planning to kill me just don't go to bed
I'm the second you're good it's only one
day this pool but for real let's stop
kidding around and written and
appreciate the places strolling around a
gross Emma Terry right now you could
show this to the cops right if you were
really that scared it's a loop of him
just strolling around a cemetery he
keeps getting new footage and splicing
it into the live stream so we've seen so
wait is this footage new how would he be
running the live stream I don't think
it's new well no that's
it's got to be older right yeah because
he has to be in a situation like them
out there yeah
Patrice can you please give me a [ __ ]
break
it's definitely Patrice it's a black
man's hand with bracelets I recognise
that wrist and bracelets anywhere are
you kidding me I'm seeing in my
nightmares so many times
Oh Patrice I'm I'm sorry I never meant
this is the repeating this is no it's a
continuation yeah this is a continuation
it's not repeating it's not repeating do
we just lock in and watch this I got a
piece I think this is a continuation
it's just so weird what happened at the
house nothing apparently she's got
ladders everywhere to learn something
read in the garage blank screen it's all
black
oh he said something he did no [ __ ]
way
What did he say I don't know what are
they saying in the chat what are they
saying I don't know I just saw someone
say he was saying something speaking to
us there's another stream they're saying
hold on let me see there's another
matter strong yeah how long creepy [ __ ]
creepy [ __ ] well I see one now but I
guess there was two at one point I'm
gonna call the police for trace if you
keep this [ __ ] up I'll miss Jay I've
called the police
stop you [ __ ] creepy secret Ethan is
gay somebody said let's call him a
creepy saying right let's wrap this up
trace I'm done giving your creepy ass
yeah we're done with you Patrice it real
come at me we got shot he's on deck he's
a big guy though he's Jax it's like the
most Jack dude ever here let me find a
pic of my purchase Wilson Jack Tracy
Wilson Jack that's what I'm typing
imagine this guy coming at you like what
the [ __ ] am I gonna do against that he's
also got like a oh my god I was from her
cell ready good the thing is is that he
looks like it makes enough guy yeah yeah
this is really weird he does seem like a
nice guy that was the guy my god he was
like a sweet soul it's just really weird
but I'm still pretty good ways that
you're shot oh that is just being
it's got like a swole like a [ __ ]
it's what happens when you're Buffy yeah
like he look so mischievous but like
maybe looking see I'm so helpless
against him I'm leaving town on December
1st are you you're not helpless kind of
against that no you're not I got a piece
so bad we have to wrap this up okay nerd
you want to keep going
I could be now let's wrap this up we got
[ __ ] we all got [ __ ] to do the stupid
trees let's do it I'm on Patrice watch
for the rest of the night well guys
thank you so much for coming and riding
with us ride or die
Thank You Austin for joining us my yeah
my favorite absolute favorite guest
always a joy and a pleasure I love you
buddy I love you guys yeah thanks for
spending your time with us appreciate
you guys so much
SoundCloud Spotify YouTube you know how
it goes
apps iTunes all that [ __ ] whatever you
know is books Oh watch out for that new
album I'm squeezing you guys will know
when it's on I'm squeezing my dick is
f2p so bad you have to pee that bad yeah
I'm squeezing my dick I really gotta go
I'm squeezing my [ __ ] dick
we have jontron coming up
well the dates out I don't remember the
days it's like next Wednesday that's it
that's all we got that's the show so
keep an eye on Patrice y'all if I get
murdered yeah I say Jim keep keep us
both updated on social media so we know
the suburbs yeah keep it please this man
I don't know
I really don't know Thank You torch
twitch Prime subs god bless you
right social media great question
I think some Mota file I'll look I have
to be so bad I don't want it to end but
I need Stan's bad in my life what is
with him why is he getting all wet
oh look at this guy legal we go round
we're gonna dig around poetry legal
bound coming soon
this guy is dude are you kidding me he's
been pumping for some reason those abs
will break me and a half and that
hairline forget about it
I think the daggers gonna run in my
heart I don't know these guys
Ethan alright I gotta pee I gotta end
this guys thank you for watching we'll
see you next week baba was there by now
[Music]